plays Commissioner Gordon in the final
season of Gotham he wrote this week's
episode that airs as always Thursdays at
8:00 Eastern Time and if he wasn't
friends and flag football teammates in
middle school with Drew Brees what would
Brees have done without Ben McKenzie
good to see you sir yeah we reconnected
recently he did you really yeah my wife
threw me a surprise 40th birthday was my
birthday in September and happy birthday
thank you very much yeah thanks
eight months late it was a surprise
birthday request surprise so if how
would your I mean if your wife didn't
put me on the invitation that's true
it's her if I don't want to throw your
wife under the bus then but you're
putting me in a very difficult position
she got people to record videos and it
was everyone from people I grew up with
including true to um to people you know
in my life now who couldn't make it and
and he recorded a video which was very
sweet and so that put us back in touch
and we talked it was nice
it's amazing what he's turned into huh
brother it's incredible he got robbed he
got our I'm not over that neither his
drink was awful that was just awful
really seriously worst non-call I've
ever seen I can't I mean I'm not a guy
who's into the but it's the system has
to change how can I hug you I know that
I don't think they're gonna I don't
think they're gonna change it the
amazing thing is did you see the
Superbowl commercial that Drew Brees was
in with all the former NFL players that
a few watched actually didn't yeah it's
incredible they were oh no there were
all these football for turning football
players almost a hundred of them to
celebrate the hundredth anniversary the
NFL Drew Brees was sitting next to Alvin
Kamara in it they shot that that his one
Scene two days after the NFC
Championship game the ultimate the old
me handled it like a gentleman he did
awful he did there's a photograph of him
without my Camaro my god you could see
he's kind of got that look on his face I
can't believe I'm here for the NFL after
we just got screwed by the refs that's a
rough one anyway I know so good to see
you sir thank you for being here
Brockman what are you you threw some
numbers at bad defense when he walked on
the set here what do you have a really
yeah obviously been huge
Texas Longhorn football fan they've got
some odds for the next season your
quarterbacks a Mellinger 18 to 100 and
the Heisman Wow and the championship
next year Texas 18 to 1 win the
championship really well I may need to
go to Vegas
do you go you could just flip money his
way he's good for it yeah you want to
lay a long horn back down for Ben
McHenry it's like a charity auction item
like that pretty much how do you love
you had a love Bevo russian ago ever
seen coming right out let's see the game
yeah we're back I mean we i-i've been
very cautious in the past as you made as
we've talked about on the show but I
actually think and I'm well I'm so
cautious but I'm optimistic I think I
think we got though we got the tools
yeah no Bevo was Russia's arrested it's
okay okay we can replay machines any
time yeah I think we got the tools I
mean we now we got um all of a sudden
we're getting offensive line prospects
in the last like month we've they're
coming in we need we need some
foundational stuff there but um you know
we got that we got all the skill players
who we got - there isn't knowing you're
from breeze breezes high school right
isn't he from yeah yeah he went to
oscillate Nick Foles - uh yeah it's
pretty amazing yeah did you go - that's
cool I did not
I should not we went so we went to st.
Andrew's Episcopal middle middle school
yeah
thank you there's some dangerous people
and yeah and and then I went to Austin
High the oldest High School in the state
of Texas okay because I'm a
traditionalist and plus we lived in the
zip code and and then he went to was
like at Westlake is the power house you
know the west leg for football right and
they just stomped us I remember being a
I was strong saftey and wide receiver I
remember remember meeting their fullback
in the hole he just ran right over me
and into the end zone and I don't think
I've ever been hit that hard in my life
and I think he might have laughed as he
ran over me but he didn't literally
laugh it out like he then trucked you is
that what you're saying
trucked me like like like like when your
teammates won't look you in the eye
after the play that's that's when you
know you got truck did breezed were you
playing against Brees yeah yeah yeah
yeah so you're patrolling the secondary
and Drew Brees is fading back to pass
did that happen yeah must have I'm
trying to remember we yes we played them
in the playoffs my junior year or was I
senior I think I was my junior we hadn't
made the playoffs in 20 years and and we
got trucked and I got rocked we got
beaten badly and I can't remember I
think Sheree was was he must been
starting must of if you're in the same
age and everything s I know he he
celebrated his 40th birthday the day the
night of the beating the Eagles in the
playoffs he celebrated that night his
wife threw him a party that I wasn't
invited to either well now I feel
terrible just it's lost its it's kind of
like my SP invitation it's lost in the
mouth for the last 16 years how did you
get to University of Virginia by a plane
actually no I drew I drove nice roof I
might go to Texas you didn't want to go
or you need to you know I love Austin I
just wanted to change designer II sure
my dad went to UVA as did my grandfather
which isn't the reason that I went there
but it don't take some history there you
know I had a great time there I loved
UVA and they have a girl hell of a
basketball team they had a big win last
night did they not Chris broccoli no
Syracuse was up at the half and we
played great in these first half's and
then she better don't
when you shooting 90% from three in the
second half what are we supposed to do
yeah yeah somebody jarred one from 31
feet away right particularly like that I
know I know
where was that shooting against Duke
they needed that the worst way I know
yeah bring that up I'm sorry no I'm just
walking through the sports no the world
would then Ben McKenzie here season 5 of
Gotham you wrote the episode that your
co-star Aaron Richards is directing this
week everything is done correct Kerrang
done your yes and how do you feel about
that great okay you know we were making
not this last season we made 12 this
last season but normally we've made 22
episodes a year which means you start
shooting in July and you don't finish
until the end of March and you know it's
just it is a lot of work which I was
very happy to do but I'm also very happy
to not have to do it sure right it's
just an intense and intense scenes that
you were shoot intense settings yeah
yours yeah yeah you've got an easy TV
show to put on the air right and of
course you were finishing your season
every year in January February March
we'd finish somewhere in March and you
know you're in New York outside in
January February and March that's a
rough one it's okay now you know crime
ear everybody but it was um
it was a great experience I'm very happy
I think we I think we accomplished what
we set out to accomplish which is which
is to fill in this gap in the mythology
they haven't ever portrayed in a
live-action setting the origin stories
of all of these characters and they've
never done a Commissioner Gordon
centered story right again in a
live-action setting so we filled that in
and we and like like all of the previous
iterations we add our own little
contribution to it everyone talks about
oh this is against the mythology or this
is in keeping with the mythology but if
you actually read the comics that
mythology is kind of right all over the
place there's different interpretations
of everything and I feel like and we had
fun and and and the show is especially
for network TV really I think unique
it's dark and weird and twisted and we
couldn't do the sexual content of course
because we're in our TV but but in terms
of dark humor and violence we definitely
had our you nailed it all and Chiklis
you got Chiklis out of there before the
Patriots could win another one my god I
know he's impossible if I have to hear
one more story about his dog Tom Brady I
love you know he's a great guy you got
it
he brought T b12 to this show one day
energy that question yeah he brought T
b12 with him and I I was cradling tv12
yeah
and how jealous will he be that the
actual tom brady now offered me to train
with him for next year's 40-yard dash
it's fact
why after I did my 40 and I failed
miserably and my personal best attempt
he can I ask you a it went sick so flat
that's good it's not bad my right leg is
still yelling at me if I'm run from two
days ago see I'm turning 50 yeah I'll
have my wife invite you did you stretch
before you did this oh my god I worked
out I stretched I did everything I put
the cream on I put the yeah that no
clear no clear I didn't do the clear
needed you know is a recipe for pulling
a groin or something it's exactly right
fact see worth it it is actually because
we raised her only know one speed that
is correct
thanks for coming on man really Congrats
on this Thursdays at 8:00 Eastern on Fox
the finales uh me uh NFL draft night so
I'll have to hit the so you won't be
watching but DVR I will DVR that and
largely DVR that how about your
Southland uh colleague Regina King Oscar
baby no that's how cool is that
she's one of my favorite people she's
incredible she's in Krabi you gotta talk
Lakers with her I know that oh yeah um
she is she's awesome that was
I confess I didn't watch the rest of the
ceremony I watched the first that's half
hour well it's a good thing the timing
was right she nailed it J on it and then
you could say just flip it off that's
right good to see your thanks Haman
anyway gets Ben McKenzie at then
underscore Mackenzie on Twitter at mr.
Ben McKenzie on Instagram the Rich Eisen
show weekdays at noon eastern on
audience